alors dimitri vas-y pas de boîte à
questions bois chéri il faut il que tu
peux tu nous garantir que tu feras sur
ces 8 au mois de septembre ou là alors
là on leur a alors latin comme ça
intéresse tout le monde se calme et on
se et s'ils jouent du ska messoudi ils
se sont dits ou va être en septembre je
descendais on va être si je le redis on
va être sur les cli data veut dire que
tu es demande et pression puisque le
corona dimitri la question est
pertinente est intéressante et c'est
rare que qui est des questions comme ça
alors des téléspectateurs et des
chroniqueurs jamais jamais jamais jamais
jamais donc mon dimitri je te le dis
aujourd'hui je suis en mesure de tenir
qu'à 80 12 % avant j'étais 90 avant de
commander à 92% un même acte pour
amérique et même on va pas se mentir à
pratiquement 100 % à moins que la chaîne
ferme parce que voilà je peux pas savoir
ainsi la fin des geeks mais pour
l'instant la chaîne se porte bien je
serai sûr c'est vite à la rentrée est ce
que ça te fait plaisir pour eux un bien
un bravo ah bon ça te fait plaisir
alors je vais te dire et je voudrais
remercier surtout le groupe canal notre
grand patron tous nos patrons parce que
je vais te dire vraiment j'ai eu des
petits soucis dernièrement et ils ont
été avec moi à fond ils m'ont jamais
lâché je voudrais remercier aussi et je
vous jure c'est vrai les personnes dans
la cure à prix qui a eu un petit souci
dernièrement voilà je vous en parlerai
pas ce que ça a l'air de voile à 2 2
bien se passer et a eu le patron de m6
qui a été exceptionnel voilà je voulais
dire patron de w9 exceptionnel que
j'embrasse forum où jérôme fouqueray
nagui arthur voilà je le dis voilà nagui
arthur exceptionnel mais surtout les
potes à la chaux pas seul et gad elmaleh
franck gastambide tout ça bien entendu
cela ils sont tout le temps l'armée
habitants etc
mais c'est vrai que voilà ces
personnes-là exceptionnel donc je
voulais les embrasser très fort bien sûr
tous les chroniqueurs qui sont toujours
avec moi et qui sont des amours voilà je
voulais vous dire
et donc voilà et les pertes et personne
de canal+ voilà ils sont avec moi au
fond c'est la famille voilà francs
capitaux maxime saada
voilà bien sûr il ya vincent pujol il ya
tout le monde toute l'équipe williams
ont gérald brice viret que j'aime
il ya tout le monde voilà il ya
alexandre israël tu es formidable aussi
et c'est vrai que voilà on est on est
une équipe on est une team et on s'aime
énormément on est très soudés et notre
grand patron est toujours avec nous et
nous suit dans tous nos délires donc
voilà donc on voudrait dire merci au
groupe canal voilà merci les cherry et
merci à jean christophe thiery aussi
voilà qui est souvent avec nouveau chéri
voilà et frank cadoret voilà donc voilà
donc normalement je serai sûr c'est vite
à la rentrée ce que ça te fait plaisir
dire ce que vous voulez que je ne peux
pas non non pas du tout parce que moi je
te suis depuis france 4 bat à un amour
mon dimitri et ben je te fais un énorme
bisou et tu embrasses ta femme
et si tu veux un animateur pour le
mariage écoute je prête à tu sais moi tu
me donnes je vais te dire des raviolis
chaud et je peux en être au fait des
gros bisous